hi welcome to my lair what does a
fashion blogger and a bear both like in
the winter a good lair no hi mister life
is different now this has been a trend
I've seen on YouTube for a long time
people have been recreating each other's
Instagram photos but I thought today
would be a great day to recreate some of
my grow memory cards Instagram photos
one we have spent a ton of time together
in the 10 plus years that we have known
each other thus far - she is currently
out of town and I know I will not see
her until at least Monday so I will not
know her she thinks this sucks but I
watch a lot of people do this and I
think it's really fun I thought it would
be really easy and it turns out this is
very very difficult that's it that's the
intro here's the video yeah okay we're
in the parking garage of the shopping
center that I'm going to and a fun game
that I play with myself is that the
ticket for the parking garage is free if
you shop within an hour that's the time
limit I'm giving myself also I don't
want to stick around here my stomach
doesn't feel like right yay let's do it
let's find some mamrie clothes okay we
made it up some things let's go back and
try to recreate memories Instagram
photos I took longer than an hour I have
to pay three dollars
like I said we're back from shopping we
got some things to try to put together
some semi-decent
looks for some memory right instagrams I
think what I'm gonna do first is some
memory makeup because all of the photo
that I'm trying to recreate generally
have the same type of makeup memory has
big bright blue eyes I around chip eyes
choices like a wing thick liner on top
with eyelashes and usually like a red or
orange lip oh I'm gonna put some falsies
on ones that I already used in my last
video you might say cheap and/or
disgusting
I say its forceful and/or eco-friendly
Earth Day is coming up I'm a better
person than you are deal with it that's
what the lashes on and turn into me my
heart I figure if we just get a base
memory on then we can try to jump from
Florida photo also it's like 6:30 7
o'clock at night now and the Sun is
setting so I might have to do some of
these in the morning because some of
them require outdoors with Sun also I'm
trying to do them by myself so we'll see
and also I don't want to leave my house
to do them so we're getting a real
resourceful when you look at Mary's
Instagram she doesn't have one of those
you know millennial
gen Z theme is going on but you can
definitely find some smaller themes car
selfie with beans with cocktail cocktail
with beans and then you have a complete
array of miscellaneous I'm trying to
pick some of them that I think I could
try to do by myself
with my resources okay lashes are on I'm
gonna do the rest of my face makeup and
we'll be right back tada I think I did a
pretty yeah
I'm becoming Mary I think they're pretty
standard memory makeup look we got big
doughy eyes and big bread and big bread
lips now what do I do
let's let's do it let's do it okay I'm a
face ha so the first Instagram photo
we're gonna try and do cuz it might take
the most to do it by myself it's this
one she's looking for somebody talked
before without any of the like promotion
of a show she's doing stuff on it and it
told my favorite pictures of memories so
I have to yellow skirt neither one of
them have pocket cuz memories hands are
in her pocket well fake it a blue tank
top that looks like the one that she is
waving I don't have a red wall just
shoot in front of in my house nor do I
want to leave my house to do this shoot
so I'll probably try and find a plain
white wall and shoot in front of that
and see if we could photoshop some red
it okay we have transformed in torment
yeah there they are hi friend into our
memory inspired outfit huh maybe I'll do
it oh this is the Nook that I now have
it just collects a bunch of [ __ ] maybe
we'll do it in here that's normal ish
colors professional photographer shot
this photo so I'm working with a
handicap here
okay Oh after 200 photos I think we've
got as close as we can get on this one
moving on okay so now we're moving on to
main refill cover I have my hair so
short to do a top bun but let's try
let's do we can do here we go I tried to
look for our green shirt like hers in
the book cover and I couldn't find one
anywhere I went and then I realized I
have this dress so I can just pretend as
the shirt he's got a blue background and
she is leaning on like a magenta table I
think I just try and do it on this and
see if I can put something on this table
like I said these are all a stretch she
has a face Manhattan who know but if it
was real on the neighbors shoot in her
class I have this class but I don't have
any cranberry juice or anything to put
in a food coloring and water look
obviously not the name come but close
enough let's see if I can do it this
photo okay one steel frame and that is
gonna work I this is so hard by yourself
alpha change this is just what I want to
wear right now the next one that I'm
gonna try and recreate is pretty simple
it's been rearing a light pink hoodie
and it says boiled peanuts and I know
for a fact that she made this herself
with iron-on letters because that's what
we do I have a light pink OD that I
bought from H&M and a bunch of iron-on
letters and things and such so let's see
if I have enough to spell up well
peanuts shall we look everyone else is
doing these recreation videos it has a
much easier time perhaps because they're
blood type isn't oh no let's get our
iron and iron these letters on
boiled peanuts follow the easy thing
about this Instagram from memory is that
it's definitely just done as a selfie on
your iPhone so I was just in front of a
dark background so I can get oh my god
maybe this red lipstick is too much I
think it is okay let me take off the red
lipstick there we go photo some sort of
quarrel up it's just probably just her
natural lip color because she's a
goddess she's an effortless got it let's
let's try to take some selfies good
morning wow it's the next morning and
like I said I needed sunlight to shoot
the last photo that I want to try to
capture from memories Instagram and if
this gives you any indication of what it
is it's a ferocious one it's one of my
all-time favorite photos of memory it's
gonna be a little difficult to try and
capture by myself but I've gone this far
and I bought this from forever 21 so
we're gonna make it work okay
so let's make some coffee and make our
mamrie face okay so makeup is basically
done in the photo she's got this like
her koi is headwrap thing from this head
wrap at forever 21 yesterday I mean I
could have searched a little bit harder
and longer but that's for dicks this was
quite taken outside by a professional
photographer in the sunshine and right
now in Los Angeles
it is so overcast I'm a little back
patio in my house that I'm gonna set up
to try and shoot the photos out there
because I'm shy and I don't have gone to
public to do it so I don't have a
chain-link fence like she does so we're
taking some creative liberties let's set
that up
I think we got it we got it we got it
well then I go there was my attempted
recreation of some of my favorite photos
on mamrie Hart's Instagram do you like
this video give it a thumbs up don't
forget to go follow memories Instagram
so you can fully appreciate and
understand how much work goes into a
seemingly effortless mametown Instagram
so leave a comment down below there's
anyone else that you think I should try
to recreate the Instagram photos of
because this was actually albeit hard
very fun don't forget to subscribe to
this YouTube channel I make videos at
least two a week ish so if that bill
notifications so you know when those go
up because no one knows I don't even
know and with that I don't know you know
that you're a crazy person
okay influencer when you drink your
coffee out of a mug with a photo of your
own dog on it and not only our dog but
your dog wearing merchandise that you
used to sell Oh while you're wearing a
hoodie with your own Twitter handle on
it oh I've become a parody